okay well welcome everyone it's a
pleasure to be working with you today my
name is Joseph Lapointe and I am a Human
Resources leader at Thermo Fisher
Scientific I have over 30 years of
experience I've had a number of
different HR roles in my career but
career development and leadership
development are a couple of my my
passions and today we're going to talk
about some strategies around building
your personal brand so when you see a
famous brand such as the brands listed
here in the slides such as Nike and
Apple and Starbucks and such obviously
when we see those we have you have some
preconceived notions of what that brand
is all about and if you think about it
similarly when someone sees us or hears
our name at work we we have a reputation
right because of this it's really
important that you build a positive
brand and reputation certainly within
your your current organization and
certainly that's going to translate to
outside the organization as well so
today we're going to cover a few
different things one is we're going to
cover how to position your value how to
leverage your network we're going to hit
briefly upon you know making sure you're
keeping your social media profile such
as LinkedIn and other professional sites
up to date and how you can really bridge
your brand in your current role so
hopefully when you leave the workshop
today you're going to be better people
you know better prepared to articulate
your accomplishments leverage your
networks both within your current
organizations and outside hopefully
keeping your profile in a position to
help you network more effectively and
and really hopefully you'll be be
motivated to take advantage of what
you're currently doing in your current
role to strengthen your reputation
communication skills and and
relationships moving forward so when you
think about positioning our value I
think a lot of us feel that the work we
do should speak for itself now certainly
it goes without saying that achieving
your goals and getting results are
imperative but it's also poor important
for us to be able to speak effectively
to our accomplishments because if you
think about it and you maybe even think
about your current team you know the
person who who you report to or your
manager may have many direct reports and
sometimes they don't always have full
visibility or the time to take notice of
all the individual contributions of
their team so really that responsibility
you know is incumbent upon us to
articulate all that all that we do and
all that we achieve so we're going to
delve into a little bit about the art of
talking about yourself and if you think
about it at least in my humble opinion
it is really an art to be able to talk
about yourself you know most of us are
really you know might be uncomfortable
doing it but hey at the end of the day
we have to be our biggest advocate so we
should always be prepared to really be
in a position to give a concise overview
of you know what we do what we solve so
we've achieved and what our career
aspirations are and this is simply
called your elevator pitch you know so
picture yourself the year at the
corporate headquarters and you're in you
in an elevator with an executive that
you want to know or you're getting
coffee or something like that you've got
60 seconds to give that to give that
overview of who you are what value you
bring and where you hope to go so a part
of this pitch obviously is talking about
what you have achieved now it's
important to be able to summarize your
accomplishments over you know the last
six months the last year things of that
nature and it that really demonstrates
and shows your impact and the value that
you that you bring now as I've mentioned
is you know you are your biggest
advocate and you know the most about
what you've accomplished so in order to
build your brand and enhance that brand
you really need to be able to share what
you've done however it's important to
keep in mind when you talk about your
accomplishments it really needs to be an
engaging way right we've been in
conversations where you know you've been
engaged to someone and you drift off a
little bit because you know they just
drone on and on and on so obviously
understand that people will stop
listening if you just list off what
you've achieved or if you take ten
minutes just to talk about maybe one of
the projects that you've done
think about your recent accomplishments
and and really organize your thoughts
into an engaging easy-to-follow story
now let's keep in mind that it's just
not about what you say about yourself
but also how you say it how do you build
your brand past what is just on that
piece of paper we call our resume well
I'm a firm believer and maybe fell on
you know being from the Midwest is that
you know you really need to balance
humility with confidence yes certainly
with a you know somebody that could have
influence over your career or you know
somebody hiring for an open position you
know they want somebody who's going to
who's going to do the job right so again
you need to balance that humility but
you need to be confident you also have
to have authenticity it's really
important you know we've all encountered
we've been in situations maybe where
we've met somebody or interviewed
somebody and they really weren't
authentic so what I really mean by that
is you know don't over inflate your
accomplishments and intake you know
don't take ownership for more than what
you did because obviously in today's
world you know we don't work in a vacuum
we work with others and work through
others as I've mentioned already it's
important to use stories that make your
accomplishments memorable make it
impactful you also need to get people in
your corner and this is really really
important and what I mean by that is
it's really important to build a strong
network of people who will vouch for you
and who really know what you're capable
of this is going to go a long way
especially if you're a candidate for a
new role or a project I could give you a
real vivid example of how important this
is one of the business units that I
support we were just in a a search for a
marketing leader and given my experience
at the company I have a lot of
relationships
across the organization and the
candidate that we were interviewing as I
was interviewing this individual we
discovered that we had a couple of
virtual acquaintances within the company
a thermo Fisher Scientific so certainly
what's the first thing I do when we we
can tell at the interview I hadn't
touched face with this person for a
while so gave me a great opportunity to
touch base and reached out and you know
we exchanged some pleasantries got
caught up of what's going on and I sort
of led him to say hey you know Matthew
you know we interviewed this individual
I won't mention any names and even
before I could finish the sentence my
colleague Matthew you know gave a
glowing recommendation and that held a
lot of credibility to me and I shared
that with the hiring manager and I'll
tell you at the end of the day that was
one of the differentiating factors that
helped us individual get the you know
get the offer to for a pretty decent job
so again these go a long way again
especially if you're a candidate for a
new position or maybe for a key role on
a project I know this one's a little bit
squishy but it is true if you want to be
considered for the next level you really
need to think at speak and even look
like you're already working at that
level I know that sometimes hard to get
around because there may be not a lot of
context behind that but just sort of
keep that in mind and I really do think
that if you keep these things in mind
it's really going to help you position
position yourself for success and really
enhance your individual brand
so you know you've done the work you've
really developed that elevator pitch
you've you've started working on your
networks and you're already and you know
this great position comes up whether
it's within your current organization or
something you're looking at outside and
you're getting ready for that that key
part of the equation which is the
interview I just want to spend a couple
of moments here to talk about some tips
that I've developed over the years of
you know of conducting thousands of
interviews so this is obviously you know
another opportunity for you to to build
your brand by really nailing the
interview and I like to you know go back
to a code I think I remember Benjamin
Franklin once said is that by failing to
prepare you are preparing to fail and
even to this day I see candidates
whether they be internal candidates for
internal roles or folks from the outside
really making the mistake of just not
preparing you know it's critical and
it's very important to prepare for the
interview in order to be successful and
I really think the first step to prepare
for you know in interviews you know we
all expect we're going to get some of
the typical interview questions right
you know such as you know tell me about
yourself
why are you interested and if we ever
really thought through that you know
that could you know maybe not get things
off on the right foot but by preparing
you will not be as nervous and you're
going to really sound more collected and
articulate during the interview and you
need to be able to clearly present why
you are a great candidate for the
position you're interviewing for the
next step is to prepare for behavioral
based questions and what I mean by
behavioral based questions is some you
know if the other person interviewing
you
then you know trained most interviewing
training Falls around behavioral based
interviewing and that's really based
around the notion that the best
predictor of future success is how we
behaved in the past in similar
situations so you really need to be
ready you know for questions such as you
know tell me about a time when you had
to manage manage change in difficult
circumstances or you know tell me about
a time you had to resolve you know a
complex customer issue where the
customer was not happy you know those
types of things
interviewers you know you we use this
method to find out how you behave in
certain scenarios so we have an
understanding or a level of confidence
that you know when presented with the
similar scenario or similar situation
this is how you're going to react and
respond so again I really would
encourage you to focus on this and
really use the method where you
succinctly describe the situation you
know describe the situation what you
asked to do what you chose to do and
what the ultimate result was I think
this is going to really help you frame
this story very clearly and leave that
interviewer with with what you
accomplished then we know that
conversation is wrapping up you know
hopefully you never you're just going to
ask what questions do you have
interviews are not a one-way street
you should be interviewing the
organization as well is a critical you
know critical decision so do some
homework it's important for you to not
overlook this part of the conversation I
know when I go to a lot of interview
debriefs one of the things that gets
discussed is you know you know a
candidate we didn't really have have
many questions you know were they
interested were they unprepared you know
that type of thing so make sure you do
your due diligence and not overlook this
part of the of the interview this
your opportunity to find out more about
the job about the organization about
your future team your future boss things
of that nature but don't make the
mistake of asking questions that it
could've been easily answered with some
simple research such as you know tell me
about what your company does or things
of that nature that that is a big
turn-off and you know don't be afraid at
the end of the interview as well to ask
about what the next steps are or when
you can expect to hear back regarding
the position and certainly you know it
means it means a lot to me and I think
it's it's polite and it's a you know
best practice to you know write a simple
thank-you note or email back to the end
of individuals interviewed you this not
only shows gratitude to the interview
team but reminds us you know the
homeowner who interviewed you would
remind some of their interaction you
know so you might also want to use that
as an opportunity to reiterate a couple
of key points of why you feel you're the
best candidate for the position so we're
going to talk a little bit about
networking and networking is certainly
critical I think I should know that
maybe when somebody's been at an
organization for a while day individuals
might take the network for granted
however it's really imperative for your
development to leverage your network
both internal to the organization as
well as externally so again some simple
tips here you can certainly look at the
slide it's really important again you
know it's again one of those types of
things that folks some folks do it
seamlessly some folks may find a little
bit difficult if they you know might be
a little bit on the shy side or a little
bit more introverted but you know reach
I learn from your peers always be ready
network there's opportunities to network
almost every day you know within within
your organization obviously you're with
colleagues right now you can network
with take some notes ask them
non-traditional questions it gives you a
great opportunity to practice that
elevator pitch and really putting your
personal brand to the test again it's
both an art and a science and the more
you network I think the more you're
going to learn and obviously if you're
always learning you're continuing to
grow and develop and that's going to
definitely enhance your brand so now
that I've shared some networking tips
let's talk about how you can put those
into practice and let's look at your
your career Network and again we won't
go through the exercise per se since I'm
not in front of you but again this is
just a simple tool that I've used in the
past that you can help draw out your
career network you know you can choose
how to capture it yourselves but you
want to be you know in a position get
out a piece of paper and start looking
at who are the key people in your
network that you either you know utilize
today to share best practices and such
or maybe individuals so you need to
connect with to get to that next level
in your career
so again this is sort of you know a
simple diagram here sort of this picture
yourself here in the in the middle in
that box it says me you can start Luo
for example listing some of your
internal contexts of networks that may
be in the current department you work in
on other networking contacts you have
outside of your department but within
the organization in those external to
the organization so the simple message
here is just to start mapping that out
and start writing down some names
so again think about who the key people
inside and outside the company that you
can learn from and have you know clear
the development discussions with that's
certainly really important assess what
the relationship is with each of these
people is it strong and effective or
does it need a little work and you know
ask yourself am i able to grow my career
through my network and if I can't you
know maybe ask yourself the question why
so simply here just wanted to share a
simple example again this is another
tool that I've used with folks when I've
been coaching coaching them you know
again we we we find here that Jake is a
is a connection Jake's external to my
organization I haven't talked to Jake in
a long time
the benefit of that relationship is Jake
is a real thought leader in my function
and you know connecting with Jake and
networking with Jake is really going to
help me identify some conferences that
that I might consider attending in my
field so in order for me to take action
what I'm going to do is reach out to
Jake and you know maybe say can we meet
at Starbucks and have a cup of coffee or
can we grab lunch sometime you know the
next couple of months to have this
networking career development type of
conversation so again just want to offer
up some some tips as it relates to what
you can do in your current role to help
you build your brand you know obviously
by my biggest piece of advice for folks
to to grow and advance their career is
to really do well in your current job
let's don't over look at that so again
make sure your ongoing dialogue with
your leaders and really understand the
goals and objectives associated with
your roles and in how your overall
performance is going to be measured you
know that happens through hopefully a
lot of ongoing discussion you're having
but certainly if your organization's
have formal review processes great
opportunity to do so I think it's
important to that you have that you
would really work to understand your
management your manager style and what
some of their pet peeves are so you can
so you can avoid those again
communication is key right so don't be
afraid to ask for feedback you know
don't make any false assumptions you
don't know what you don't know so make
sure you are an active participant in
that in that dialogue again building and
maintaining relationships both on the
personal and professional fun are key
network with your peers get their advice
in maintain those relationships and you
know step out there attend events or
volunteer in situations to get you
exposure to to new people you just never
know what that might might uncover but
at the end of the day really I think
attitude says a lot so I would really
encourage everybody to be real positive
and really you know have that can-do
type of attitude be willing to roll up
your sleeves that that does go a long
way I do know being in an HR capacity
those things are really noticed you know
overachieve under-promise and
over-deliver right you know give
Morgan's requested that that really does
a lot about does a lot of positive
things obviously for your brand and it's
certainly you know be passionate and you
know sometimes put your shoes soft in
the shoes of your manager you know
they're it's a tough job and they've got
a lot of things to to factor n but maybe
look at what you're doing through their
lens is as well and that might help you
identify some opportunities and things
of that nature
so a couple things I'd like to challenge
you with as you as you leave the
workshop today is to you know leverage
your network by following some of the
steps that I've outlined for you here in
the workshop
I think it's always key to ensure that
you've got an up-to-date resume and in
social media talent profile you know
such as LinkedIn or other professional
networking type of type of sites they're
being utilized more and more and more in
the talent acquisition game so that's
key and again you know you've got an
opportunity to continue to build and
enhance your current brand by excelling
in your in your current role so
hopefully you found this informative I
wish I was there with you but please
feel free to anytime to reach out and
connect I'd love to have a conversation
thank you for your time